black item 2 is officially on the back
burner with Dwayne The Rock Johnson
announcing that for the time being a
sequel to his recent superhero
Blockbuster isn't moving forward in the
DC Universe sad yes yes this follows
Patty Jenkins third Wonder Woman film
being scrapped in addition to removing
Henry Cavill as Superman with new DC
Universe film heads James Gunn and Peter
Safran beginning to build out their DC
Universe through their creative life
yeah there is the the whole point here
and in a heartfelt post the Roth broke
the news that a Black Adam sequel won't
be coming anytime soon stating James
Gunn and I connected and Black Adam will
not be in their first chapter of
Storytelling however DC and seven bucks
have agreed to continue exploring the
most valuable ways Black Adam can be
utilized in the future DC multi-universe
chapters yes Dwayne adds James and I
have known each other for years and have
always rooted for each other to succeed
it's no different now and I will always
root for DC and Marvel to win and win
big in response to the Rock's statement
gun adds love the Raw talk and I'm
excited to see what he and seven bucks
do next can't wait to collaborate soon
now in response to the backlash gun
previously tweeted our choices for the
DCU are based upon what we believe is
best for the story they are made with
sincere hearts and integrity and always
with the story in mind
oh break down here when I heard about
what James Gunn was doing on Twitter
there was a hashtag fire James Gunn but
he's like no that's not going to happen
so he's co-cfo to Peter the fact is he's
getting rid of Gal Gadot he's getting
ready to Henry Cavill as Superman and
black on them may not be happening so
here's my problem with this whole thing
because Black Adam comes out love it or
you hate it whatever it is he was able
to bring Henry Cavill back as Superman
later on Henry Cavill says I'm back a
Superman Man of Steel number two is
going to happen and then now he gets rid
of him James Gunn gets rid of him as
Superman we love him as Superman the
only issue with this now is Henry Cavill
had to give up The Witcher thinking he
was going to become Superman so where
does he land now those whole story then
leaving The Witcher so where does he go
I don't know so are you a fan of
Superman like definitely definitely a
big fan of Henry as Superman and I was
excited I'm sure a lot of fans were
excited when he announced that he was
coming back and it was kind of like a
pump fake like everyone was excited and
all of a sudden it just got cut and now
he's left with neither roll yeah which
is kind of unfair to him I feel like he
should be yeah so he's it seems like
James Gunn is the Kryptonite are in the
situation and he's clean slating
everything he wants to go back to his
origin story so I don't know if this is
going to work I think he's gonna do a
lot more CFI there's not gonna be a lot
of Storytelling with his new movies but
I feel like we've already been there but
you have to bring back Dwayne Johnson as
Black Adam I think he's it's you know
that was his passion project for 15
years and the fact that he brought him
back is is brought back Superman is a
big deal but also Gal Gadot the fact
that she was celebrating doing number
three and that's not happening as well
so I don't know what's happening in the
dceu world uh he mentioned that he's
going to tell us more details in January
what's going to happen but I I'm gonna
have to believe in him the only good
news is Batman is still the in place
when Matt Reeves is still there and
we're also going to see Robert Pattinson
as Batman so that's good news but I'm
feeling a little bit uh what is
happening there's some speculation about
the Marvel Universe for Dwayne The Rock
Johnson what do you think about fans
speculating I'm talking about Marvel and
bringing that into his tweet yeah so
that is interesting in a statement that
he wrote Marvel I wonder why he wrote
that does not mean he wants to jump ship
I just can't see that happening because
Black Adam is part of DC so I am not
sure but uh he puts so much work into
that and the fact that this one person
comes along and says no I am cleaning
everything out we're not dealing with
this anymore so let's see if this new
world will survive I hope it does